[Music]
so I'm Bradley
yeah all right these guys are famous for
their pranks they are famous for not
only for creating and running this
amazing show but they also like to have
fun with the cast they do and they like
to have sometimes it can have it can go
a little far and I understand it the
joke was on you this season so firmly on
me and it served me so right because I
was the guy who always said what kind of
dope falls for their stick every time
I'd heard of somebody else getting
pranked I thought see right through
there so lo and behold we get our script
for the new season and it's the scene
where Sam goes home goes back to home
and it says in the script we see Sam
dressed for dinner Sammy is now
resplendent in a in a purple bright
purple frock coat pink tights pink slip
on shoes and a pink box hat so I'm
reading this and my suspicions weren't
around at all because I've done quite a
trusting guy and also I thought you know
because we've never seen Sam at horn
Hill before some obviously just dressed
like a prick at home
I wonder poppity wanted him out the door
just what he used to wear around the
house yeah so so III grammo great so I
went I went for a fitting in Belfast he
went this far
well we'll treat we have a picture here
I think my favorite thing about the
picture is your face like I'll do this
if I have to
you're such a trooper I thought was
gonna look like that's why I thought I'm
gonna look like you guys clearly spent a
lot of money and went to great lengths
just to do that just to screw with this
man this time I said they're not doing
themselves any favors because anybody is
getting a guilty conscience about pirate
in the show for budget reasons are
thinking all they've cut budget or not
but were there wasting budget
you